this video is made possible by nord VPN
get nord VPN at nord VPN comm forward
slash biographic so use coupon code bio
graphics get a three year plan for 70%
off plus use our code biographic sand
you'll get an extra month for free just
go to nord VPN comm forward slash bar
graphics and let's get into it
even those who aren't familiar with the
name olive Oatman are undoubtedly
familiar with her photo
the young dark haired girl with the
solemn expression and distinctive chin
tattoo has become synonymous with the
hardships faced by the pioneers who set
out as part of America's westward
expansion a mass migration that helped
shave the middle of the 19th century
even as thousands of intrepid settlers
made their way across the Midwestern
Plains on the Oregon Trail groups of
Mormon pilgrims headed to another
destination Salt Lake City and still
others headed deep into the southwestern
deserts for reasons that were entirely
their own and that is where the Oatman
family was going when they were waylaid
at the place now more realized with a
single plain sign that reminds travelers
what happens there
the Oatman Massacre the teenager olive
survived the attack that killed most of
her family and experienced a life that
few lived to tell of she's most famous
for her time spent among the Native
American tribes of the American
Southwest but her story begins much
earlier than that with visions prophecy
and religious fervor
immigrants who packs up everything ends
left the relative comfort of the East
Coast for the wild landscape of the West
did so for all kinds of reasons some
were just out for adventure and some
well it wasn't so much about where they
were going but more about what they
wanted to leave behind for the omen
family their foray into the western
frontier began with the revelations of a
prophet
Roy's Oatman and his wife Mary Ann had
seven children between 1834 and 18-49 it
was also during those years that the
Methodist family converted to Mormonism
after being inspired by the prophecies
and texts revealed by Joseph Smith for
those not familiar with the foundations
of Mormonism it's worth a quick aside to
understand just why the open family
would leave behind the relative safety
of the Mons and head west Smith claimed
to have found a set of golden plates
that he was able to translate with the
help of an angel he preached that it was
their duty to seek out the city of Zion
and along the way they would meet a lot
of resistance believers were tarred and
feathered to run out of town and
persecuted for their beliefs and there
were a lot of believers including Royce
and his family in 1844 Smith announced
that he was going to run for the
presidency however not all those who
considered themselves Mormon agreed with
the move or all of his teachings for
that matter one of the most
controversial was polygamy and it was
enough to splinter his followers into
other groups after Smith destroyed a
press run by one of these rival factions
he called on the local militia for help
he was arrested jailed and On June the
27th the mob broke into the jail and
killed him
one of the rival factions that had been
a thorn in Smith's side was headed by a
boy named James Colin Brewster Brewster
had been only 10 years old when rumors
of his gift of prophecy began to
circulate at first the mainstream Mormon
elders believed that he was a genuine
seer buoyed by this Brewster started
bringing the revelations fast and
furious ultimately writing with the help
of his father a text he called the book
of estrus included in the text was a
description of the promised lands it was
a land designed to be the gathering
place of saints and it was called
Cydonia the lands of Bashan Brewster
claims that the lands was in a remote
corner of the country somewhere in the
southwest Smith and the mainstream
Church
anounced Brewster as a fraud and
Brewster gathered his own following
appropriately they were called the
Brewster rights and more formally they
were the Church of Christ The Omen
family were among Brewster's followers
and at the time Smith was killed the
young would-be prophet was just 17 years
old but that many decided was old enough
to lead the faithful to the promised
land even though he had officially been
excommunicated from the Mormon Church
before Smith died his prophecies they
began to get more specific and he
claimed their final destination was on
the river Amelie which she claimed was
another name for the Rio Grande so it
came to pass on August the 5th 1850 the
Oatman family left Missouri and a group
of about 90 people there were 17
different families in their little
Caravan made up of 27 wagons a few
hundred cattle and as it would turn out
quite a bit of strife
today travelling across the country can
be done in less than a day Airlines
they're uncomfortable they're
inconvenience and they're one of those
modern luxuries that no one really seems
to like but it's almost an infinite
improvements over the conditions in
which the Oatman family and thousands of
other families needed to try to survive
on their Trek westward one in ten people
who set out on the Oregon Trail did not
survive it was an active route for only
25 years but it still has the dubious
distinction of being America's longest
graveyard with around 65 thousand graves
scattered along the way that's one
burial every 50 yards from Missouri to
Oregon City there was no shortage of
ways to die disease was rampant and in
some cases a person who was perfectly
healthy in the morning would be dead by
dusk there was cholera scurvy malaria
and of course there was always the
possibility of snakebites Falls broken
bones infections and accidental gunshot
wounds something that happens more than
you might expect
just imagine the hardships surviving on
nothing more than the dried food you
could carry and what you could hunt dust
and dirt in fact at every nook and
cranny and if you were among the latter
settlers that set off you are following
in the footsteps of thousands of other
people and animals and trekking through
all the waste that was left in their
wake
it's truly not surprising that tempers
might be running wild and the conflicts
within groups who needed to stay
together for safety might be commonplace
things only got worse for the rooster
rights as they left the plains and
headed into the mountains of New Mexico
traveling routes known to the natives as
Granada dam were toe or journey of death
it wasn't just difficult terrain either
it was one of the longest hottest and
driest years on record and those that
lived there were getting desperate as
the caravan of devout families travels
they passed more and more ominous lands
marks human remains picked clean by
scavengers dead and discarded pack
animals Goods and garbage that oxen were
no longer strong enough to carry so you
might be able to see why the omen family
only traveled with the rest of the
resources far as Las Vegas as historians
say is when the party split 26 people
including the oatman's and three other
families set off in the direction of
California while the others followed
their prophet the splinter group headed
along the
El Camino Real and in January of 1851
they made camp at La Jolla they worked
for a cutting and delivering hay
before moving on Maricopa wells by this
time they knew they were being followed
cooler heads prevailed at first and the
group decided to wait at the Pima
villages until they were joined by
travelers who were inevitably coming
along behind them greater numbers would
have made them a less tempting target
but again it's possible to see why they
would just want to get on with their
journey and reach their destination
after three weeks of waiting Roy's
decided that he and his family including
his wife who was due to give birth any
day we're going to push on they were
going to be doing it alone
as no other families would join them
their destination was Fort Yuma a
hundred and ninety miles away that
doesn't sound far in our 21st century
world of wide roads and fast cars but
the omen family would have been
trundling along at a pace that was at
the fastest between 15 and 20 miles per
day a lot can happen in that kind of
time and a lot of things did happen
horrible things the omens decided to
take a shortcut but they were slowed
down even more their oxen were ill
suited to the terrain they found
themselves crossing and they were
struggling to get up and down the rocky
hills and plateaus On February the 18th
1851 they spotted a large group
approaching there were between 17 and 20
members of a Native American tribe the
details of exactly how the confrontation
happens are understandably scarce but
it's believed Roy's approached the group
who demanded pipes and tobacco that Roy
shared but when they demanded food and
were not satisfied with a bread he
offered he told them that he didn't have
enough to feed his own family much less
them the conflict escalated and by the
time it was over all but three word debt
in a later memoirs olive Oatman
describes seeing the broken and bloody
bodies of her family members scattered
across the ground then she fell into
unconsciousness olive and a younger
sister Mary Ann weren't killed
they were taken captive and when they
woke they spent several days on a march
to the village of their captors almost
immediately they were stripped of their
shoes making it almost impossible to
walk much less run away Oliver wrote of
those first few days when the grief was
fresh and they were still coming to
terms with the fact that everything had
changed and a heartbeat
she wrote of stopping to make camp of
watching a cooking fire built saying
they boiled some of the beans just from
our
wagon mixed some flour with water and
baked it in the ashes they offered us
some food but in the most insulting and
taunting manner continually making merry
over every indication of grief in us and
with which our hearts were ready to
break we could not eat there was one
more survivor Lorenzo who had an
important part to play in his sister
story he survived only by sheer luck
later describing waking with the mangled
remains of my own parents lying nearby
my scalp torn open my person covered
with blood alone friendless in a wild
mountain dismal wilderness region
exposed to the ravenous beasts and more
to the ferocity of more than brutal
savages and human shaped demons
incredibly he managed to make his way
back to the Pima village and the safety
that they left behind joining up with
another group headed for California
along the way here in the family who had
taken him in stopped at the site of the
massacre theremins were buried in a mass
grave and Lorenzo would embark on a
quest to find his sisters who were not
among the dead okay so all of this is
pretty intense so let's take a 60 second
break and let's have our spirits lifted
by the glory of today's sponsor Nord VPN
if you're buying things online and using
a public Wi-Fi spot you know think if
you're a coffee shop or something like
that you really should be using a VPN
and that's where Nord VPN comes in now I
know it's tempting not to bother sort of
just hope for the best but really those
stories you read about people having
their data stolen they do happen and
let's not make it easy for that person
to be you whenever I'm browsing on
public Wi-Fi
I just keep Nord VPN running in the
background all the time I just don't
even have to think about it don't worry
about it at all but it's not just about
security you can also use it to change
the country you appear to be and so you
can get content that might normally only
be available in specific geographic
locations Nord VPN super fast so
watching a video is a breeze it's no lag
whatsoever if you've ever used VPNs and
thought they were slow well no more with
Nord VPN and you can use it on all of
your devices very very easily Android
Chrome Windows Linux and on six
different devices with one account they
might have heard about the Nord breach
in the news recently but it's important
to point out that no user information
was exposed because Nord VPN doesn't
keep any logs on its servers because it
doesn't give any logs at all
however Nord VPN this
moving to a 100% own server model unlike
most other VPNs and they're also
improving other aspects of their
security
so start protecting your internet
experience today with Nord VPN at Nord
VPN comm /ba graphics or use the coupon
code buyer graphics get a 3-year plan
with 70% off plus user code by graphics
and you'll get an extra month for free
just go to Nord VPN comm forward slash
buyer graphics and let's get back to the
video
[Music]
maryanne barely survived the March the
village carried part of the way by one
of their captors when she grew weak
olive later said she was so utterly
fearless of death she could no longer
walk nevertheless they made it to the
camp the arrival of the raiding party
was greeted with dancing singing and
merrymaking and olives description of
life among them isn't for the faint of
heart they described a village where
women were the laborers and principal
burden bearers and where she and her
sister were immediately put to work as
slaves only the slightest excuse was
needed for whippings and beatings to be
handed out but it was the foreboding
sense that something much worse was
waiting just around the next corner just
coming with the next dawn that truly
took a toll
olive later wrote there was no Beauty no
loveliness no attractions in the country
possessed by these unlovely creatures
sometimes I would tell Mary that I saw
that there's all chance for escape that
we had better be good and ready for any
fate and try to wait in submission for
our lot months into their captivity and
Oliver wrote that they became more
merciful in large part because of her
sister runs in part because of their
skill that learning their captors
language the women and children they
mess were particularly fascinated with
their stories of their home of the ocean
and of their travels among themselves
though while ever described a spirit of
low obscenity and meanness and they
would regularly ask the girls if they
wanted to escape a question they didn't
dare answer honestly fortunately for the
girls a nearby group of Mohave had been
trading with this group for several
years and finally they came only after
all have said months robbed by finding
us early and late at our burden bearing
and torturing labors plying hands and
feet to heed the demands of our lazy
Lords and the taunts and exactions of a
swarm of heathen urchins
sometimes set over us the Mohave
emissary was made up of five men and one
woman their appearance gave the girls
hope that if they were sold they may
find their lot in life even slightly
improved and they were souls maja they
paid for them in horses blankets and
food they were on the move again and ten
days later they came to the mojave
village here Oliver wrote they found a
home they were welcomed into the Chiefs
home and taken into the care of his wife
the women who had negotiated for their
purchase had been the Chiefs daughter
and her sympathy toward their place gave
them a better life that they hadn't
dared to dream of much less speak of
when the sisters had been shocked at
their captors life stalin's their
apparent inability to survive on
anything they hadn't killed or stolen
and the harv a family even gave them
their own plots of land to go crops they
were expected to contribute to the
tribes welfare and they did they
gathered wood don't for roots planted
and harvested crops and forage for
berries they made friends - they were
given nicknames into the facial tattoo
that would make olives appeared so
distinctive and strange in the eyes of
the world that she'd been born into it
was done to both Mary and olive and it
was a painful process their skin was
pricked and a pigment made from the
powder of river rocks and the juice from
weeds was rubbed into their bloody skin
painful yes but it was a mark of
friendship and of respect they were
family and as family the Mohave did all
they could when Marianne grew weaker and
weaker
she died in 1855 after a long illness
caused by a lack of nutrition it wasn't
just Mary on either grouse had made food
scarce and olive later remembered
travelling for days to find berries that
would sustain the dying for just a
little longer
she helped tens of the sick administered
medicine and felt the devastation that
came with failure then she would travel
for days again searching for birds eggs
for roots for anything that could
prolong her sister's life until the
rivers were filled with fish again but
for all our efforts and the efforts of
the chief and his family
Marianne passed away she sank into the
sleep of death as quietly as sinks the
innocent infant to sleep in its mother's
arms while tradition dictated that the
bodies of the tribes dead were to be
cremated the Chiefs wife
appealed to her husbands who allow olive
to do as he wished with her sister's
body and she was ultimately buried
according to her own traditions now
olive was truly alone safety continued
kindness of the Chiefs wife and daughter
which
sustained more than any bit of gruel or
a handful of corn years passed and
Lorenzo never gave up the search for his
sisters he joined expeditions of
explorers and prospectors see searched
the length and breadth of Southern
California for even the slightest bit of
information or indeed of hope they were
still alive even petitioned the Governor
of California for help and got a
response that the atom wanted the
governor had no authority to do anything
Lorenzo's determination kept the girls
plight the talk of the towns and that
meant he wasn't the only one looking for
his sisters in 1853 a man named Henry
Grinnell passed through Fort Yuma and
heard the tale of the two young girls
who had been taken captive finding those
who were lost was in his blood he was
the nephew of another Henry Grinnell who
used the profits of his shipping company
to funds the voyages that went in search
of Sir John Franklin who went missing
during his attempts to find the
Northwest Passage a Grinnell was a
carpenter but an inquisitive one he
asked so many questions for so long that
he was finally approached by a Native
American man who had some information
his name was Francisco and he asked
Grinnell about the girls in January of
1856 Grinnell who pretended to get his
information directly from the newspaper
he was holding told Francisco that the
American government knew there were two
girls being held against their will in
the southwest
he agreed they were prepared to go to
war to save them unless that is their
captors saw fit to release them
Francisco promised to bring the girls to
safety in exchange for a few blankets
and some beads he only asked for 20 days
and promised he would return even as
Grinnell was ridiculed for his faith
that the emissary would is indeed do all
he could to rescue the girls Francisco
really did head off to the mojave tribe
where olives still lived for her parts
Oliver knew that the attitudes of the
chief and his wife seemed to change and
finally she came to realize that someone
was indeed trying to bargain for her
release the mojave didn't want to let
her go though even going so far as to
tell francisco that this wasn't the girl
he was looking for she wasn't American
they insisted she was from a faraway
tribe that lives in the same direction
as the Setting Sun they told olive to
tell Francisco the same but when it came
time for her to talk she told the truth
she was
threatened with torture called a liar
told they were simply not going to let
her go but they did a beautiful white
horse was added to seal the deal and
Olive visited her sister's grave one
last time before she left for Fort Yuma
Rijeka mating wasn't easy for Olive
she had transitions almost completely
from speaking English and when she
accompanied blowing the Chiefs daughter
returned to the fort she was quickly
given more appropriate clothing to wear
she was given over to the care of women
working in the fort and Lorenzo read
about her return in the same paper
Grinnell had pretended to read from
confirming it was true he headed back to
Fort humour and they were quickly
reunited here is about where Lorenzo's
part in the story ends he traveled with
a sister for a bit living with her in
California in New York eventually
married and Scott into the hotel
business but died unexpectedly in 1901
as for olive she struggled to readjust
the life she'd been taken from she kept
her promise to the Mojave whenever she
spoke about them she told stories of how
kind they had been she denied that she
had ever suffered at their hands and
after the Reverend raw Byron Stratton
wrote a slightly embellished account
about her life among the Mojave
she used a part of the profits from the
Birkins her time on the lecture circuit
to send both her and her brother to
college in 1865 she married John fair
Charles they moved to Texas and after 10
years they adopted a baby girl she died
in 1903 and although she occasionally
used makeup to cover her tattoos for
pictures she never entirely turned her
back on the way of life taught to her by
the Mojave until she died she always
kept a jar of hazelnuts in her kitchen
one of these staple foods she had once
collected for a second family so I hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe brand
new videos four times a week on this
channel also please support us in the
mission to make those videos by
supporting our sponsor Nord link below
and thank you for watching
[Music]